brevity is the soul of wit ah JA maiden
piece of that while he was quoting
somebody else hey guys I'm Ryan right
this is ready ready first time on the
channel yes she just started getting to
know her today pretty much Veronica
introduced me to her she's awesome
weird quirky as paraplegic crappy
paraplegic ha ha
yes paranormal powers or something yeah
Randy's an actress and she's actually
done some acting work before which is
even cooler it's so weird being an actor
and doing acting work you know what I
mean though there's a lot of actors who
are act who don't actually do anything
she's seen one of these episodes before
who no one and that was the big hero 6
movie clip video and had no idea what it
was yeah she because we didn't really
explain what it was in the video
everyone got upset at me for doing that
video because they're like dude the
second trailers rudia why did you watch
that instead so that's what we're gonna
watch today Brandi OH see how I did that
see how I did that big way segue not
like the one you ride but like the other
one the word transition type yeah I knew
people will love you I knew it I knew it
okay watch this okay
this is the first test of my robotics
project
the shuttle test
this distant Aki my older brother
thirty-third testers 84 test
hello I am baymax oh this is amazing you
wanted to help a lot of people people
keep saying Josh she's not really gone
as long as we remember him
hello I am baymax Tadashi programed me
to heal the sick and injury there
I'd like to help scan complete you're
experiencing mood swings diagnosis
puberty whoa what thanks Bernie
reports are flooding in about a major
catastrophe we're under attack from a
super felon people show a man in a
kabuki mask attacked you and balloon
mate trust me I know about robotics we
could be way more anybody else's suit
riding up on them take it down ha
why is Dana wearing carbon fiber
Underpants
this may undermine my non-threatening
huggable design oh he's gorgeous
Wow love this I'm terrified
what's wrong with you bad everything
gave me a heart attack me or nothing
it's just an expression what do you say
buddy
okay gets back luggage
oh I'm so cute
he's like Iron Giant yeah my god Stay
Puft Marshmallow Man that's a great way
to put it but except but except nice
yeah it was kind of evil oh yeah
marschallin that was pretty terrifying
yeah that movie looks it looks funny
it looks like a funny movie it looks
really cute my I have a concern though
about it um yeah it's a real concern is
will the two stories mesh well together
it seems like it's just like buddy movie
about them and then the last half looks
like it's gonna be like this superhero
film I don't know if it's gonna play out
like that cuz I won't get started if it
feels like two different well you know
what else did that um what's the movie
where the little kids and she's like I
saw saw free um and he's like the bad
guy and it's dang it I forgot his name
but it it's the guy and in and he's like
the this is good damn it this is good no
it's terrible I love bringing people on
to no movies no put the little girl and
she had like the littles cute little
things and she sees that giant unicorn
she's like a sovereign if you know what
she's talking about you can just comment
below oh yeah I mean that is my one
concern about the movie is will these
two worlds mesh well together but as far
as everything else goes you know it's
from the guys who've created like
amazing animated movies yeah if it's
those dudes this has to be good but
frozen you know we just started a big
debate I know this is your first time
coming on the channel we're gonna start
off with I don't like frozen too much it
wasn't that I didn't like it I just
think that they were qualities that were
inherently wrong with its story Hey look
I wasn't a big fan of frozen I feel you
feel but I would never see my first well
I wanted people to love you Brandi well
I'm not Elsa oh um Despicable Me yeah
yeah that's what it is yes we figured it
out yeah that's what this episode is
really about the storyline is kind of
the same like this buddy-buddy like him
finding his heart with a little kids and
then going on to fight the bad guy so
they can be done well because this
pickle I mean with them all I think yeah
buts pickle me it's it starts off with
just this kind of work like if they just
establish the villain early on I'm sure
they'll solve all the problems one of
the voices is a cape boy from The
Incredibles and there's another boy who
is a comedian for God's name
there are lots of comedians as these I'm
sorry
as yeah it's a season sorry all right
guys if you're new to the channel you
can subscribe to the real rejects she
kind of has a YouTube channel but
instead I'm going to tell you about her
Facebook page go to her facebook
facebook.com slash Brandi price dot
actor Don actor yeah thank you spell
your last name price you know like how
little are you but don't say that cuz
that's just terrible I know what you're
talking about
Price is Right our price is right you
say price is wrong [ __ ] we're going
somewhere random with an I know why not
I like the drink you do not like black
girls gotcha no no yeah yeah yes so yeah
some racist
it's just how their culture rich looking
oh that's horrible no that's mr. Issa I
should cut that out of this why do I
always make these kinds of jokes on kids
movies all right just be sure left a bit
I'm like way off to the right yeah my
channel now you make sure I'm in the rut
okay what do you mean um enough to the
right the whole time uh probably
oh Jesus Christ became a swear word
that's true yeah weird well I think it
was more of like it just not necessarily
an expletive but just something that you
say they're like Oh God but it could be
or Jesus well sometimes you're like mad
at people like Jesus Christ man and it's
like I think it just evolved into that
yeah yeah
you think originally it wasn't it and
even atheist use it yeah all a theist
use every single one of them see rivers
no go north I have a rather interesting
username does that qualify for a shout
out sea rivers go north yes it does
here are the qualifications for a
shout-out you ready you ask for Linda
it's that simple or you do something
that makes me go this guy I needed say
something about a guy but so far you've
done the qualifications congratulations
what Cyril is go south is I like
negative and North is the positive C
rivers the rivers go north and will not
see what this goes south that's his evil
twin probably do you have an evil twin
comment below what are you doing right
now
I have to load this person's shadow I
totally promised them this girl was like
having the roughest time in her life oh
just like Colorado laughs that's cool oh
she's not it really much time so I'm
gonna give her a shout out her friend
asked for it can you shout out to my
friend she's feeling like [ __ ] no she's
she's been going through a lot I don't
know
I understand now but that's just like
the worst way to say hey you've been
having a real shitty day I'm gonna send
you a shout-out
Valentina Pastor Rick Reza
yeah apparently life has been a little
rough around the edges for her so I
wanted to say hi to you Valentina you're
beaut
full and you stay that way don't change
it do your best not to seriously once he
hit 30 he gets rough but you're Italian
you have good skin you will last people
and that's there's some really hot older
Italian ladies that might be just custom
at Italian I think you're biased
well Italians are the dominant race
let's face it what yeah how did that
what why would you just look at history
look at it I'm looking at history not
feel like what are you denying
nomination anywhere we rule in terms of
a cinematic history okay maybe
cinematically there's some good stuff
yeah I don't mean like real American
history I wasn't talking about American
we're telling history yeah well history
more world history what's the word but
Valentina this is your shadow so Tina
you're awesome you're awesome
you're beautiful and you're Italian and
remember we are bonded because of that
you will forever have he's only half
bonded with you though ditch why would
you you know she's having a rough time
and you're cutting her down really
channel cutting her down is she you only
want to be half bonded with him I'm just
just letting you know that's fair
actually fair right he might cry now
sure if I if I mentioned Ryan Gosling
you might cry oh don't mention Ryan
Gosling you didn't cry right now
Watson right Ryan Gosling I wanted to
shout out this is when you qualify in
terms of you deserve a shout out my
friend Justin Rittenhouse he's the one
who asked for Valentina's shoutout so
that is sweet I don't you said can I get
a shout-out to my amazing Italian friend
who brought me to this channel that's
awesome that's awfully sweet but she's
just your friend are you trying to bang
her or is that what you're trying to do
cuz I could totally redo that whole
shout out
I'll give her another one if you really
want to get laid by her right that's
okay
try to help a guy out man this guy knows
how to get the ladies veronik is amazing
but this guy
I was about to play off of that was like
too funny but Justin dude Rittenhouse
listen if you love Valentina you don't
stop pursuing her don't saw the leave in
don't never stop believing never I
believe we were gonna shoot this in ten
minutes it has been 20 well he was
looking for shoutouts for a leg Tony a
little minutes
Justin rented house you are not a
Rittenhouse you are a beautiful house
you are the foundation of love peace be
with you if you want to bond to the
other half one you can yes right the
other house waiting for you I'm half gay
it's Jim something you call bisexual